[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Siebers einen guten
Freitagabend ihnen allen seit fast Z
Jahren tobt russlandskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und ersetzt immer noch furchtbar
Rekorde was die Menschen landesweit in
der Ukraine heute seit dem frühen Morgen
erdulden mussten sind die schwersten
russischen Luftangriffe seit langem
möglicherweise sogar seit der Krieg
begann weit über 100 Raketen und Drohnen
praktisch jeder Bauart über 150
verletzte noch weitere die unter
Trümmern vermutet werden und mindestens
31 tote wir haben gestern hier im
heutejournal über verwundbares junges
Leben berichtet in einem Krankenhaus für
Frühgeborene heute wurde in nipro eine
andere Entbindungsklinik getroffen und
ein Einkaufszentrum Terror gegen Babys
Mütter einfach alle so wahllos wie inf
Farm Alisa jung ist
dort da fliegen sie Teile ihrer Wohnung
einfach aus dem Fenster dieses
meerrfamilienhaus in nipro wurde durch
die Druckwelle eines raketeneinschlags
so heftig beschädigt dass die schben
zersplittert sind dimitro raskas und
seine Nachbarn sind immer noch unter
Schock wütend dass sie ihre Kinder
beschossen werden von Russland mitten im
Schlaf die Schuhe braucht ihr nicht
ausziehen und die Tür auch nicht
zumachen wermer wird's nicht bitterer
Galgenhumor was bleibt einem anderes
übrig wenn das eigene Leben buchstäblich
ein Scherbenhaufen
ist es passiert ist waren wir alle zu
Hause das eine Kind im Bad das andere
mit der Frau kdor und ich war
hier und blieben alle wie durch ein
Wunder
unverletzt ich bin vom Flur hierher
gerannt um mein Telefon zu holen und als
ich zurück war hörte ich das Geräusch
dann die Explosion die Türen wurden
rausgerissen und es flogen überall
Scherben seine Frau Marina und die
beiden Kinder Kina und jah
hat er sofort danach zu Verwandten
gebracht nur die Papiere und eines der
heiligen Bilder nahm seine Frau mit sie
haben überlebt der Angriff ist keine 5
Stunden her da kommt der ausmesser für
die neuen
Scheiben hier räumen sie auf vor dem
ausgebrannten Geburtshaus und dem
Einkaufszentrum wo jetzt ein schwarzes
Loch klafft es war einer der heftigsten
Luftangriffe auf die Ukraine seit
Kriegsbeginn es wurden alle notwendäte
atzfahrzeuge zuerst zum Geburtshaus
geschickt weil sich dort Gebärende und
Säuglinge befanden im gesamten Land gibt
es Tote und Verletzte war es Vergeltung
für das russische Kriegsschiff was die
Ukraine vor wenigen Tagen getroffen hat
für die Menschen hier spielt das keine
Rolle sie müssen einmal wieder ihr
zuuhause aufbauen und weitermachen trotz
der Angst dass so etwas gleich morgen
wieder passieren
könnte als ich die Situation etwas
entspannte und sich der Rauch des Feuers
verzogen hatte raffte ich mich zusammen
und kam her um aufzuräumen das Leben
geht ja
weiter die Apotheke die kaaffes in der
Straße hatten auch heute den ganzen Tag
geöffnet die Helden des Alltags in der
Ukraine beim Beschuss der Ukraine hat
Russlands Armee offenbar auch NATO
Luftraum verletzt nach Angaben des
polnischen Militärs flog eine russische
Rakete heute morgen etwa 3 Minuten lang
über Polen dann habe sie den Luftraum
wieder Richtung Ukraine Verlassen der
NATO Generalsekretär erklärte die NATO
sei solidarisch mit Polen und bleibe
wachsam zu uns nach Deutschland aus der
Luft sieht man das ganze Ausmaß und aus
der Luft kommt jetzt auch Hilfe fast
ganz Niedersachsen stehe unter Wasser
sagt die Innenministerin in Hannover
heute der Ministerpräsident ergänzt so
etwas habe es in seinem Bundesland noch
nie gegeben
100.000 Helferinnen und Helfer von
Feuerwehr und THW sind im Einsatz die
Lage ist je nach Ort unterschiedlich
hier sehen Sie in rot gestreift die
bundesweit am stärksten betroffenen
Gebiete und wir sehen auch schon auch in
anderen Bundesländern gibt es noch keine
Entwarnung zumal neuer Regen kommen soll
Clemenz Altmann berichtet aus perden an
der
all im fischeriertel der Altstadt von
Pferden regieren whosen und Gummistiefel
verzweifelt versuchen die Bewohner ihre
Häuser vor dem eindringenden Nass zu
schützen Sandsack um Sandsack landet vor
den Hauseingängen die ferder kämpfen
gegen einen Feind der nicht nur von
außen sondern auch von innen
kommt schwierige bzw dove Lage weil s
mal das Grundwasser es wurde extra der
Damm auf der Seite errichtet seiner Zeit
und jetzt haben wir das Problem dass es
mitten in der Straße weil das der
tiefste Punkt hier ist hochdrückt und
halt sehr sehr sehr unglücklich ralf
eltank hat so seine eigene Wasserquelle
im Garten da kommen auch die Pumpen
nicht gegen an ja hier haben wir Gulli
der kommt wir läuft was Wasser ab zum
Siegel und das druckt jetzt das Wasser
nach oben von außen drückt die all gegen
den Deich ein paar Kilometer nordwärts
sollte sie sich eigentlich mit der Weser
vereinigen aber die lässt sie nicht rein
weil sie selbst überfüllt ist und so
staut sich das Wasser auf bedroht Ralf
el zu Hause 200 Hochwasser hier und da
war das also noch nicht hier so nicht so
hoch wie jetzt hier in der
Garage Garage das Auto steht noch
drin also so viel Wasser wie bisher also
jetzt hat wir noch und wie gesagt jetzt
haben wir Wasser läuft trotzdem rein
zwar nicht so viel aber immerhin es
läuft trotzdem
rein gehört
zuingesessenen aber wie geht denen die
noch ein gesehen haben statt Freude über
das neue zu Hause nächtliches starren
auf den Pegel seit einer Woche haben wir
Umzug gehabt und jetzt war die erste
Nacht hier und haben uns eigentlich eine
entspanntere erste Nacht vorgestellt als
das was jetzt hier passiert also meine
Mutter wurd in der ersten Nacht
gesturmklingelt von der Feuerwehr ich
habe wirklich Nachtschicht geschoben D
ist meine Mutter wach geworden hat sie
dre Stunden lang geguckt ja ist wie ein
Film die örtliche Feuerwehr bereitet
sich auf noch steigende Pegel vor es
wird noch lange dauern bis hier
trockenen Fußes spaziert werden kann ja
dann gehen wir jetzt live zu Oliver
deuka er ist im niedersächsischen
Hochwassergebiet bei Hodenhagen guten
Abend Oliver gucken wir vielleicht
erstmal auf die aktuelle Lage bei dir
Niedersachsen bittet jetzt die
Bundeswehr um Unterstützung wie genau
sollen denn die Soldaten
helfen ja das ist weniger Manpower also
sprich jetzt nicht Bataillone die Hände
gebraucht werden sondern eher
technisches Gerät um genau zu sein
Hubschrauber und diese Hubschrauber zwei
hat man bekommen einmal von der
Bundespolizei einmal von der Marine die
werden dafür eingesetzt um sogenannte
big Packs also große ja
Stoffbahnen wo Sand drin ist den
transportieren zu den Deichen die weich
geworden sind um da quasi Flicken zu
können stellen die vielleicht nicht mehr
so gut sind das ganze könnte man auch
mit dem LKW machen aber da sind die Wege
dahin mittlerweile matschig man kann die
nicht mehr befahren morastig Fahrzeuge
können stecken bleiben also das ist so
eine Geschichte
Hubschrauberunterstützung
um die Deich zu sicher und um vielleicht
auch wenn irgendwo was durchbricht dann
Loch stopfen zu können wir sehen es wird
doch jetzt aktuell gearbeitet mit was
rechnen die Behörden noch vor Ort wo
liegen die größten
Gefahren na ich habe gerade schon
angesprochen das sind die Deiche ich
stehe jetzt hier nicht wirklich an einem
Deich aber das ist ein Wall aus
Sandsäcken ich glaube 45 000 S hier
verarbeitet worden und H sieht man es
ganz schön ich gehe mal ein bisschen auf
die Knie für euch hier siehst du
Wasser und auf der anderen Seite ist
auch Wasser aber da ist ein Meter
Unterschied sprich dieses wenn das
Durchbrechen würde würde es in diese
Richtung laufen 2 km entfernt ist der
Ort Hodenhagen 3000 Einwohner PAL Daumen
und wenn tatsächlich da daich brechen
würde hätten die ein gewaltiges Problem
da müsste evakuiert werden etc etc nicht
weit entfernt ist auch hier der Tierpark
der seringeti Park auch dort gibt's
große Probleme also das ist schwierig
und das gilt für hier das gilt aber eben
auch im Prinzip für den ganzen Bereich
bisschen hat sich das mit dem Hochwasser
verschoben wir hatten das erst im
Südosten Bereich Hz etc jetzt hat zwei
Tage nicht so richtig doll geregnet
alles aus dem Harz das Wasser was ich
gesammelt hat kommt die Flüsse runter
und ist jetzt eher so im Nordwesten
Niedersachsens vertreten das wurde eben
gerade auch aufgezeigt wo die gefähdeten
Gebiete sind und größtenteils sind es
die Flüsse die jetzt Ärger machen weil
die Pegel einfach hoch stehen die Deiche
langsam durchsickern hier bei Hodenhagen
beispielsweise geht die aller durch die
Deiche sind relativ neu die sind stabil
aber es gibt andere Bereiche da sind sie
e nicht so stabil und da muss damit
gerechnet werden dass da durchaus mal
irgendwie ein Deich so weich wird dass
da was passieren könnte ganz
grundsätzlich wird auf Abg raten
Besucher hierherzukommen Deich zu
belaufen da gibt es Verbote mittlerweile
also man tut alles um das zu schützen
also noch einiges an bangen keine
Entwarnung Oliver herzlichen Dank für
diese Eindrücke heute Abend und jetzt
weitere Nachrichten von diesem 29
dezember in der Übersicht und die hast
du gundela aufgeteilte Resonanz sind die
Reformpläne von Arbeitsminister Heil zu
Einschnitten beim Bürgergeld für
jobverweigerer gestoßen zustimmung kam
von Finanzminister Lindner sowie von
Politikern von SPD und Union Arbeit
müsse sich mehr lohnen als der Verzicht
auf einen Job dagegen warnen
Sozialverbände usos und Linke vor
heftigen sozialen
Folgen für Silvester sind in Berlin
Neuköln mehrere proalästinensische
Demonstrationen angemeldet worden eine
davon wurde am Abend verboten nach
Polizeiangaben ist auch eine
proisraelische Versammlung angemeldet
als Konsequenz der silvesterkrawalle vor
einem Jahr werden allein in Berlin 4000
Polizisten zum Jahreswechsel
dienstbereit
sein Israels Armee weitet ihre Einsätze
im Süden des Gazastreifens aus nach
Angaben der Hamas sind dabei innerhalb
eines Tages
187 Menschen ums Leben gekommen mehr als
21500 Palästinenser sein seit
Kriegsbeginn getötet worden die Angriffe
Zielen laut Israels Militär auf
Terrorzellen der Hamas deren
Führungsspitze in hananjunis vermutet
werde Südafrika hat Israel vor dem
höchsten Gericht der Vereinten Nationen
Völkermord an den Palästinensern im
Gazastreifen vorgeworfen in der beim
Internationalen Gerichtshof in Den Hag
eingereichten Klage fordert die
südafrikanische Regierung Israel zur
sofortigen Einstellung seiner Angriffe
in Gaza auf Anordnungen des
Gerichtshofes sind in der Regel
rechtlich bindend oft werden sie aber
nicht befolgt der ehemalige US-Präsident
Trump ist in einem zweiten Bundesstaat
von den
präsidentschaftsvorwahlen ausgeschlossen
worden nach Colorado nun auch in
Maine als Grund gab die Wahlleiterin von
den Demokraten an Trump habe sich bei
der Erstürmung des us-kapitols an einem
Aufstand gegen die Verfassung beteiligt
Trump kündigte Berufung an Klärung wird
vom Obersten Gerichtshof der USA
erwartet die Finanzmärkte beschließen
ein starkes Börsenjahr der Dax hat nicht
nur die Marke von 17 000 Punkten
geknackt sondern insgesamt deutlich
zugelegte Valerie Haller die
wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen aber waren
insgesamt schwierig welche Bilanz zieht
man an der Frankfurter Börse dass es
eben tatsächlich besser gelaufen ist als
erwartet angesichts der Krieg und eben
auch der wirtschaftlichen Unsicherheiten
ein Grund dafür ist dass die Inflation
zurückgegangen ist und anlege auf
sinkende Zinsen hoffen sowohl in den USA
als auch in Europa das beflügelt die
Börsen denn niedrigere Zinsen machen
Aktien gegenüber festverzinslichen
Wertpapieren interessanter der DAX ging
stark ins Jahr und legte dann vor allem
im November noch mal eine Schippe drauf
beendet das Jahr dick im Plus mit rund
20%. für das kommende Jahr sind
Börsianer zu zuversichtlich und gespannt
vor allem wegen der eben angesprochenen
anstehenden US-Wahl und einer möglichen
Wiederwahl Donald Trumps und wer zählt
am Ende zu den Verlierern und wer zu den
Gewinnern wir fangen mit den Gewinnern
an zwei Gewinner sind schon mal SUP und
Siemens die es laut Handelsblatt im
börsenranking dieses Jahr wieder unter
die 100 wertvollsten Unternehmen der
Welt geschafft haben die ersten Plätze
in dem Ranking belegen die Tech riesen
Apple und Microsoft im Dax ist der
größte Gewinner reinmetall der Konzern
profitiert davon dass westliche Länder
aktuell wieder mehr Geld in Rüstung
stecken größter Verlierer war Zalando
für den Onlinehändler scheinen die
goldenen Zeiten der coronapandemie
erstmal vorbei zu sein Valerie Haller
vielen Dank und auf ein
neues zum Jahreswechsel gehört immer
auch die vier schanzenournee der
Skispringer den Auftakt in Obersdorf hat
am Abend Andreas Welling
gewonnen ein Traumstart für die
deutschen Schispringer der 28-Jährige
Andreas Wellinger siegte vor dem Japaner
rioyu Kobayashi und Stefan Kraft aus
Österreich die beiden Oberstdorfer
Philip Reimund und Karl Geiger landeten
auf den Plätzen 6 und 7 das
Neujahrsspringen am 1 Januar in
garmisparten Kirchen überträgt das ZDF
live ab 13 Uhr
45 das ist das Ende der Welt habe schon
eine neue bestellt singt die deutsche
Band Clan wenn es so einfach wäre aber
wir haben nur eine Welt und wir sind mit
ihr in diesem fast vergangenen Jahr
nicht besonders gut umgegangen der
Zustand der Welt in der wir leben ist
besorgniserregend darauf können wir uns
vermutlich alle einigen und dennoch
werden sie alle 2023 natürlich immer
auch ganz individuell sehen aus ihrem
jeweiligen Blickwinkel wir auch hier im
heute journal hier ist unser Rückblick
Anne gret Oster guckt auf das was kaum
zu ertragen war und auf das was Hoffnung
gibt trotz
allem um dieses Jahr zu fassen braucht
es erstmal
Abstand also reisen wir doch zu den
Sternen zumindest in deren
Richtung seit letztem Sommer ist das
äische Weltraumteleskop Euklid auf der
Suche nach dunkler Materie bis zu 10
Milliarden Jahre blickt es zurück in die
kosmische Vergangenheit des
Universums und wir schauen mit
anderthalb Millionen Kilometern Abstand
auf unsere Erde in eine erst wenige
hundert Tage alte
Vergangenheit in der Anfang Februar die
Erde bebt in der türkischsyrischen
Grenzregion und unfassbare 50 000
Menschen
sterben in Syrien kommt nur wenig
internationale Hilfe an schweres Gerät
fehlt viele Menschen sterben unter
tonnenschweren
Trümmern auf dieser Tafel steht ihre
Schreie verstummten
hier viel Wut und wenig Hilfe zum
Auftakt eines Jahres in dem es nicht
wirklich besser weitergeht
anstrengend das ist vielleicht das Wort
was ich damit verbinden würde also ich
ich bin eigentlich so ein News Junky der
immer sagt ich versuche
alles zu lesen mitzubekommen und
möglichst viel von allem was in der Welt
passiert m auch so nah wie möglich
mitzuerleben aber in diesem habe ich
zwischendurch schon ein paar mal gedacht
vielleicht ist ein bisschen Abstand auch
nicht
schlecht dann gehen wir doch noch mal
auf
Abstand Naturkatastrophen 3 Jahre
coronapandemie ein sich immer schneller
veränderndes Klima Krieg in Europa
sicher geglaubte Gewissheiten greifen
nicht mehr Unsicherheit lässt fest
geglaubten Grund schwanken in der
Ukraine geht der russische Angriffskrieg
ins zweite Jahr das Sterben
auch das ist schrecklich und es ist Zeit
diesen Krieg zu beenden denn es gibt zu
viele ukrainische
Opfer doch ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht
nipo
bachmut
avdivka die Kathedrale in Odessa immer
und immer wieder treffen Putins Waffen
zivile Ziele und die Menschen
dort wir alle versuchen zu lächeln so
wie alles ist gut aber es ist
erschreckend wir wollen unser Leben
leben so wie es zuvor
war eineosion lässt im Juni den kachowka
staudam brechen Russland und die Ukraine
beschuldigen sich
gegenseitig die Wassermassen
verschlucken ganze Ortschaften und die
Retter werden beschossen der Krieg
zeichnet die Menschen auch den
ukrainischen
Präsidenten ich denke das ist natürlich
dass all das Spuren in einem Menschen
hinterlässt und auch in sein im
Gesicht ja manchmal denke ich auch daran
zurück wie er vor di Jahren war
natürlich sehe ich auch wie sehr er sich
verändert hat dass er gealtert ist aber
dann frage ich mich ob mich das traurig
macht und meine Antwort ist
nein denn jede Falte markiert einen
Lebensabschnitt ind dem er einen Sieg
errungen
hat ein Sieg über den Aggressor scheint
allerdings in weiter Ferne es fehlt an
so vielem an Waffen an Munition an
Energie und an Unterstützung durch einen
kriegsmüde gewordenen
Westen der Krieg vor den Toren der EU
hat Auswirkungen auf Deutschland die
Preise für Strom und Gas steigen massiv
Strom um gut ein Viertel Gas um mehr als
die Hälfte die Inflation liegt Anfang
des Jahres bei
8,7% und mit den Preisen wachsen S und
Unsicherheit
weiter größter Profiteur der
Verunsicherung die AFD in Hessen und in
Bayern fährt eine Partei die in Teilen
rechtsextrem ist ihre besten
Wahlergebnisse außerhalb Ostdeutschlands
ein die AFD ist kein ostphänomen mehr
sondern eine gesamtdeutsche Volkspartei
geworden wir sind also angekommen die
AFD längst keine reine protestparte mehr
wird aus Überzeugung gewählt
hauptsächlich deshalb weil man weniger
Flüchtlinge will mehr als 300.000
Asylanträge werden gestellt in
Deutschland viel mehr als in den
vergangenen Jahren Länder und Kommunen
ächzen unter der
integrationslast und die Ampel zermürbt
sich im
dreierkoalitionsdauerhickhack zuerst um
habcks heizungsgesetz es kann aber nicht
sein dass in einer fortschrittskoalition
nur ein Koalitionspartner für den
Fortschritt verantwortlich ist und die
anderen für die Verhinderung von
Fortschritt dann um das Herzensprojekt
von grünen Familienministerin Lisa Paus
zuerst blockiert die FDP ihre
Kindergrundsicherung danach blockiert
Paus das wachstumschancengesetz der FDP
die spricht von Erpressung und bemüht
sich um Haltung wir sind eine Regierung
wo gehämmert geschraubt wird das führt
zu
Geräuschen doch der echte Hammer kommt
erst noch noch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht urteilt und 60
auf Pump eingeplante Milliarden dürfen
nicht ausgegeben werden entsprechend
gibt es neuen Streit dieses Mal um den
Haushalt wir haben schon viel Streiterei
gesehen in der Ampel aber jetzt mit dem
Haushalt ist es ja noch einmal eskaliert
und das was die Ampel da gerade machen
musste in den Haushaltsverhandlungen
waren praktisch neue
Koalitionsverhandlungen da haben sie
sich sehr schwer getan sie haben die
Kurve gerade noch mal so bekommen jetzt
wird's spannend zu sehen sein ob das
auch für weitere zwei
mit anderthalb Millionen Kilometern
Abstand wirkt dieses erdenjahr instabil
unrund und nicht nur dieses Jahr die
ganze Erde scheint aus dem Gleichgewicht
geraten Kanada erlebt die schlimmste
Waldbrandsaison aller Zeiten die Feuer
fressen sich durch 15 Millionen Hektar
eine Fläche größer als
Griechenland in Österreich und Slowenien
gibt es stark Regen Überschwemmungen und
er ichten enorme Schäden
an auch auf tenerifer wüten Flammen
wochenlang es ist einer der schlimmsten
Brände auf der Ferieninsel in den
letzten 40 Jahren und in Mexiko zerstört
Hurrican US den berühmten Badeort
akapulco
50 Menschen sterben
2023 ein Wetterjahr der
extreme Toba an dem Tod und Horror über
Israel
hereinbrechen auf einem Musikfestival
macht die hamasjd auf feiernde sie
ermorden 260 Menschen fast zeitgleich
wüten sie im nahegelegenen kibutz beri
verschleppen Bewohner und töten mehr als
100 Männer Frauen Kinder
Babys wir haben ganze ausgelöschte
Familien wir haben Kinder die ihre
Eltern verloren haben wir haben Eltern
die keine Kinder mehr
haben es ist etwas zerbrochen ich weiß
nicht wie wir uns erholen sollen also
was den den den Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und jetzt diesen Angriff der
Hamas auf Israel für mich verbindet ist
eben diese ja dass man immer wieder auf
so eine erschütternde Weise vor Augen
geführt bekommt was Menschen eineinander
antun können die Unversöhnlichkeit von
Menschen und der Wahnsinn der da zum
Teil auch dabei ist also das immer
wieder so vor Augen zu geführt zu
bekommen ja das macht einem auch als als
nachrichtenprofi zu schaffen und
verfolgt einen klar auch bis bischen den
Schlaf mehr als 1200 Menschen sterben an
diesem 7 oktober in
Israel das Land wehrt sich und trifft
dabei zwangsläufig auch die
Zivilbevölkerung eingesperrt im eigenen
Land sind sie hilflos den Raketen
ausgesetzt ihren Verletzungen ihrem
Hunger und Durst tausende sterben Gaza
ist die Hölle auf
Erden die Macht der Bilder zeigt Wirkung
auf deutschlandsstraßen wird zur Gewalt
gegen Juden aufgerufen Kritik an Israel
Unterstützung für die Palästinenser aber
auch hamasjubel und offener
Antisemitismus eine gefährliche
Mischung dass so viele Menschen auch
unter dem Deckmantel der Liberalität der
Offenheit für solche Gesinnung auf die
Straße gehen das hat mich sehr sehr
schockiert wir haben es natürlich hier
mit einem Antisemitismus zu tun der vor
allem aus der feinschaft vieler
arabischer Staaten zu Israel genährt
wird aber es ist auch ein Antisemitismus
der sicherlich auch aus Unkenntnis
genährt wird Unkenntnis führt zu
Unsicherheit und Unsicherheit führt zu
Angst
was für ein Jahr und doch gab es auch
gutes tatsächlich mussten wir ein
bisschen danach suchen hier also die
heute journal Fundstücke ganz persönlich
und vor allem rein subjektiv im April
hat Karl Lauterbach die coronapandemie
für beendet erklärt und das fand ich
eine gute Nachricht auch wenn uns das
Virus erhalten bleiben wird überraschend
und erfreulich fand ich das Wahlergebnis
in Polen da entscheidet sich die
Mehrheit plötzlich für Europa für
gewaltilung gute Nachricht
deutschlandweit konnen wir für 49 €
Ticket Reisen und das war mein
persönliches Highlight die vermeintliche
Löwin in Berlin die in Wirklichkeit ein
Wildschwein war und positiv daran ist
dass es uns lehrt man muss ganz genau
hinschauen um zu erkennen wie die
Wahrheit wirklich ist
überlassen wir das Schlusswort dieses
Rückblicks einer Dame die mit dem
Holocaust das schrecklichste überlebt
hat was Unmenschlichkeit Menschen antun
kann und die mit 102 Jahren noch immer
nicht müde ist zu hoffen und zu Mannen
gibt s was was sie als Rat geben möchten
den Menschen jetzt sei Menschen ja das
ist das einzige was ich sage es gibt
keine christliches kein muslimisches
kein jüdisches Blut es gibt nur
menschliches Blut wir haben alle wir
sind alle dasselbe also respektier ihr
könnt Menschen nicht alle lieben braucht
do nicht aber Respekt gibt
Menschen Respekt für einander könnte
doch ein guter Vorsatz sein fürs neue
Jahr indem wir wieder ganz genau
hinschauen werden auf diese auf unsere
Welt am Ende dieses schwierigen Jahres
bleibt der Dank an sie alle für ihr
Interesse ihr Vertrauen und dass sie mit
ihrem Rundfunkbeitrag überhaupt möglich
machen was wir hier tun wissen was los
ist Bescheid wissen in diesen Zeiten
wichtiger denn je und deshalb sind wir
zwei auch morgen wieder hier denn noch
ist das Jahr ja nicht vorbei kann also
noch viel passieren GA ja um kurz nach
:30 Uhr schaut auch nasan göckte mir in
unserem heute journal Update zurück und
auch nach vorne von uns allen hier auch
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter den
Kameras an sie einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend 2023 war nicht nur
das wärmste Jahr seit
Aufzeichnungsbeginn sondern auch das
sechst nasseste schon im Frühjahr war
der Boden gut durchfeuchtet die
Vegetation wuchs Ende Mai allerdings
wurde es trocken Sonne und Wind saugten
Wasser aus dem Boden auch tiefere
Schichten trockneten aus aber das
änderte sich im regenreichen Sommer
wieder vor allem im unwetterträchtigen
August und auch im Oktober November
Dezember viel deutlich mehr Regen als
normal und so sind die Böden bis 60 cm
in Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen
bis in 2 m Tiefe patschnass und jedes
zusätzliche Wasser landet jetzt in bchen
und
Flüssen ja und das ist gut für das
Grundwasser aber natürlich schlecht für
das Hochwasser zumal es auch heute Nacht
noch zwischen Münsterland und Oderbruch
also im Stau des Harzes und des
Sauerlands noch mal kräftig regnen kann
vor allem in kurzen Gewittern im Süden
verläuft die Nacht trocken an den Alpen
sinken die Werte auf 2° sonst auf 8 bis
4° morgen erreichen die Temperaturen auf
Rügen und im Erzgebirge 6 am oberrehein
13° es ist also ein recht milder und
auch ein recht freundlicher Tag morgen
gibt es eine kurze
Regenpause he ist es trocken und ist es
doch durchaus Sonne mit dabei nur
einzelne Schauer sind unterwegs z.B in
der östlichen Mitte an der Küste abends
dann im Nordwesten dazu wird ein
frischböhiger Wind aus westlichen
Richtungen zum Jahreswechsel rückt dann
der Regen aus West aber wieder in den
Fokus für sich genommen sind die
regensummen an Silvester und an neu
nicht ganz so hoch aber über die Tage
summiert sich das dann eben doch und
Vorsicht ab der Nacht auf Dienstag sind
nach aktuellem Stand dann auch wieder
stark und dauerregenfälle möglich wir
behalten das für sie im Auge tschüss